Hello,
and welcome.
You know, I used to really like the
ending of the intro, and that noise is
really starting to create on me after 18
to nineteen fifty six. Oh, I like it.
I mean, the noise is a bit grating,
but, no, it's like it's a joke. Like
like, it has a narrative. I like it.
I took a lot of inspiration from the
IT crowd. I don't know if you've seen
that. At the end of their intro, it's
like this annoying crashing noise. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Have you tried turning it off and on
again? Exactly. Exactly.
And so thank you for joining me today.
I'm here with Dan and Alan from Tilt.
We're gonna take a look at how to
make development against Kubernetes easier.
Welcome. Thank you for joining me. Yeah. Thanks
for having us. Good to be here.
Yep. Looking forward to talking a bunch about,
you know, containers,
crashing things, that kind of stuff.
Well, isn't the goal in dream of containers
that it makes all of our lives easier?
So, you know,
developing against Kubernetes should be by association easy.
Is that correct?
That is Yeah.
Should be.
Sorry, l. I think I spoke over you
there.
Yeah. It's kinda hard to coordinate. Right? We
should have, like, a little arrow or something.
No. Yeah. So developing Kubernetes should be very
easy.
Unfortunately,
out of the box, it's not. But fortunately,
there's people like me and Dan working on
tools to make that the case for you.
So
not all is lost. There is still hope.
So let's start with a basic question then.
What is Tilt?
Yeah. So Tilt's like a little it's a
program that runs on your laptop
and it watches what you're doing. So, like,
as you're coding, it sees what files you're
editing,
and it will run workflows,
like building container images and
Kubacuddle applying them and everything you need to
do
as you're developing. It will run those workflows,
and then it will show you what you
need to see,
which sometimes is logs
from the running
containers.
Sometimes it's build errors
from the build. Sometimes it's, hey. Your YAML
is misconfigured.
Sometimes it's this unit test is failing.
And to to save you from having to
play, like, 20 questions with Kubikudal
to figure out where the problem is as
you're developing.
Okay. So Tilt is a sorry,
Tilt is a tool that allows me to
describe
my application components,
and then it monitors my source code,
and then makes magic happen, and my things
run on Kubernetes.
And then you go a little bit beyond
that and you allow me to see logs.
Is that a good summation of what you
said? Let
me let me interrupt you a little bit.
So Dan talked a bunch about
basically the headaches that Tilt saves you from.
But I think it's also important to note
like what it is that it achieves once
everything is up and running. And then basically,
right now,
basically by default, let's say, Docker and Kubernetes,
As you're developing your application, every time you
make a change you have to kubectl apply,
docker build, docker push. You have to do
a bunch of things. It takes time and
most importantly, in my opinion, it takes cognitive
effort. So as a developer, you have to
stop coding and then get distracted typing a
bunch of commands.
So one is that Tilt saves you from
that. So everything is automated. You basically save
your file and your application gets updated live
on your developing cluster. Then you can
test the functionality that you just wrote or
you can go on and keep coding.
The other thing that it does is, one,
it automates it and the second thing is
it makes it very, very, very, very fast.
So you can have that workflow where every
time you make a change you rebuild an
image, you push it to a cluster, the
cluster Kubernetes
spins down one version, spins up the other
one, that whole thing. But that takes time.
And Tilt also allows you to do what
we call it live reload, other tools call
it hot reload.
Basically, what this means is you save your
file, the file gets synced up to your
cluster,
everything updates inside the container without killing the
container.
And the results of all this is basically
you save your file, you blink your eyes,
the new version's up and running. So, you
get that lots
of people mention that they miss
that instant feedback from when they were working
on, I don't know, Ruby on Rails or
something like that. And basically, Tilt lets you
achieve that but
with containers
running on Kubernetes.
So it's maximum convenience
and zero headache once everything is set up.
Okay. So I guess
it's fair to say then that Tilt exists
to make people's lives easier developing against Kubernetes.
Now are there any opinions with regards to
the toolings that I can work with, or
can I use Tilt to develop any application?
Yeah.
This is this is really important to us,
because, like,
some tools like,
Bazel or Kubernetes itself are very opinionated,
and they're like, we're going to get you
to a great place
once you adopt everything that we believe.
But with Tilt, we're really into mister Rogers
onboarding,
where mister Rogers, longtime
children's television show host, always said, I like
you just the way you are.
Tilt likes your project just the way it
is.
However you do YAML generation,
whatever you use to build images,
however you're running things, we want Tilt to
have the right, escape hooks so that you
can, make it fit with your project,
whatever you're doing.
K. So that sounds great then. I can
use Tilt to describe my application, make developing
against Kubernetes easier, and you don't have any
you don't mind which tools I'm using. So
that sounds pretty awesome
so far. I'm impressed. Now do you sorry.
One yeah. One important detail is that most
tools that are kind of in the same
realm as Tilts, they use YAML as the
config file. So the way you declare all
your services and you do all your automation
and etcetera is using YAML. And, YAML is
a flat config. It's not like a programming
language. It's not a full fledged thing that
can do anything you want, basically. It has
tons of limitations.
And, a big advantage of Tilt and even
before I joined Tilt, it's one of the
things I was working for another company in
this realm and I was thinking, Oh, damn.
If only we could do that. And that
is the fact that
config files for Tilts, they're made in Starlark.
And that is basically Python, slightly different.
So, you have loops, you have variables, you
can open files, you can run system commands,
you can do anything you want. So, it's
very easy to adapt whatever you have. And
when I say whatever I mean it because
we have people writing extensions for Tilts that
we could not even have dreamed of before.
People are automating stuff that we
need to stop and think to understand what
they're doing because it's something so,
basically, so outlandish for us. And what this
means is, literally, whatever you're doing, if your
computer can run it, Tilt can work with
it.
Okay. So
you're removing YAML from my life, which right
away gets a tick. I'm very happy with
that. But I have worked with with that
language before. Sorry. Starlock. Right? That's the one.
The same one that Bazel uses. Is that
correct? Yes. Or okay. And I have found
that quite
difficult. So I'm looking forward then today to
learning how I can put that behind me
then because I I tried to write Bazel
build files before. I love the idea, especially
as organizations are adopting mono repositories
of using Bazel as a build tool. Unfortunately,
that means you have to run Bazel as
a build tool, which I've not really appreciated
yet.
Yeah. And a part of that is config.
The other part is that I generally never
have Java on my machine. So there's a
few things there. Tilt is not running in
Java. Is that right? Correct. It's Go and
TypeScript for the UI.
Nice. I I like TypeScript, and I definitely
like Go. So that's we're we're running there.
As far as, you know, Tilt Go, is
this something that you feel that all development
teams deploying to Kubernetes should be using for
their development environments, or are there any caveats
around the usage of Tilt?
I
we we say if you use Kubernetes in
prod, you need Tilt for dev. I could
imagine, like, maybe you just have one Kubernetes
deployment
and,
you know, it's it's pretty small,
that image of, like, just the one box,
you know, on the back of a container
flatbed.
But if you're if you have multiple deployments,
if you're really using Kubernetes,
yeah,
you should probably be using Tilt,
I think. And if not,
you know,
do at me, which I think is something
that people don't say that much.
Alright.
Perfect. I think
my my interest is piqued. So I think
we should share my screen. We should go
through the installation and we should start to
see how Tilt is gonna make my life
easier.
So let me pop up the screen share.
There we go.
Alright. So I'm on the GitHub repository.
Is this the best place for me to
install it or should I go to tilt.dev?
Oh, I think if you go to docs.tilt.dev.
Here you have the here you have the
fancy guide and you just copy the instructions.
Alright.
So I can install Tilt with a nice
little curl command.
And I will allow that to paste.
And I'm sure this won't take more than
a few seconds.
I've never had troubles with installations, and that's
a complete lie. Every time I try to
install something on the stream, I seem to
break through or my Internet goes down or
anything.
This is looking much better.
Finger crossed.
Excellent. Okay. So
what it's
it's okay. So step two is I install
Tilt. Let's assume this is gonna complete in
the next few seconds. What what's my first
step if I have an existing project to
to integrate Tilt into my development workflow?
If you go back to the docs page,
there's a tutorial, the first fifteen minutes.
And awesome.
So what it says there is you're gonna
need the Tilt file and, you know, there's
a Dockerfile and Tilt has a Tilt file.
It's basically
in the Tilt file, you're telling Tilt, these
are my services.
This is where the the Docker files are.
This is where the YAMLs are. Run the
whole thing. Basically, that's what that's doing.
Okay. So we configure Tilt through a Tilt
file and then these these functions, extensions, what
do we what do we call these? Functions.
Those are built
yeah. Those are built in functions. Alright. So
we have functions to represent all of the
different tasks that I may have to complete.
I guess this is goes back to what
you were saying about other people building these
integration points for for libraries and tools that
necessarily
then directly come out of town.
Okay.
Now I realize I've already made one fatal
flaw
with my ex I have a application that
I cloned and that this is not a
daemon. It's not a long running process.
So I maybe want to pick something else.
Is that correct? What is it?
It's just a CLI application, which I would
never deploy to Kubernetes, and I clearly wasn't
thinking straight.
So I will quickly grab something else.
Let's
be brave.
So
okay. I guess I need to fill in
a few blanks here before I see a
project.
Now as part see, I have a like,
this can I deploy today project as a
static site, but it needs to be
compiled first and to those assets and then
deployed into container, and then I could deploy
that to NGINX
to Kubernetes with NGINX? Is that something that
would be a good fit for the Tilt
workflow?
Let's
let's see.
It
it it certainly should be for, like, the
first level when we get to how you
can really make it fast. There might be
some
interesting
questions and caveats.
Can you repeat that description? Because I got
a bit lost. I'm trying to think through
the mechanics.
Oh, yeah. Of course. No problem. It's it's
a a Next. Js website, which means what
I need to do is build a container
image which runs the next steps, which kinda
gives me some HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript into a directory, which I
would then want to bundle into an NGINX
container
and have that run-in Kubernetes.
Okay.
I think I stand with Dan in that
we'll see.
Yeah. Okay. Sorry. This is my fault. I
didn't really think about using the CI application
here, and then it just hit me as
we were talking. Like, that's not gonna work.
Like okay. Because I would never deploy a
CI application to the for that. Alright. So
I can create a Tilt fail.
And I'm assuming
I I'm just gonna kinda make some assumptions
here. Please feel free just to correct me
any point. But I'm assuming the first thing
I need to do is
build some sort of image for my application.
Oh, I I
oh, we we now I'm I'm the one
who's a bit embarrassed that we don't see
this more clearly in the documentation. You should
just tilt up, and tilt will watch your
tilt file
so you can like write it interactively.
Here here here's what you do. You create
a tilt file
and just
just put a tilt file there first and
tilt up and let's see what happens. And
then we're gonna increment your Tilt file as
we go.
Interesting.
Alright. I like it.
Okay. So I've got the the Tilt UI.
Okay. That makes sense. That's pretty cool. I
like that.
So no resources found. So you were looking
at the Docker
Docker build function.
So let's try putting one of those in
your in your Tilt file and let's see
what happens.
Okay. So
I'm assuming this is the tag for the
image.
So can I deploy
as
okay? So this is the the image name.
Is this a tag on the end?
Tilt will put those in. So Oh, okay.
So what what what's the second parameter then?
That's the directory that you'd like pass to
docker build.
Ah, the context. Got it. Okay. Yeah. So
I can just put a a dot there?
Mhmm. Yep.
Alright. Now I guess it would make sense
if I had a docker.
So we can do this quickly.
Copy
dot slash code
worker
code,
and then run
NPM install.
And if I check my package JSON,
export.
And
but I guess right away what I'm noticing
here is that
I just use my standard dev tooling
to a certain degree to get that container
image, and then this is where Tilt kicks
in and handles all the complicated orchestration components
and getting onto Kubernetes.
Mhmm. Okay.
So we'll call this my deploy step, and
I'll copy from zero
codes.
I think it's public. I'll I'll get this
wrong the first time, but it'll be it'll
be okay.
Now
should
oh, code
public.
Copy it to here, which is the standard
NGINX directory.
Okay. So my first question then would be,
would it make sense? Because I am not
got a % confidence in my ability to
write a Dockerfile
that quickly. Now should I be running Docker
image build locally till I'm happy with that
process, or is that something that Tilt can
do for me when I add the the
function to build the image and get the
errors back?
Exactly.
That that latter one. Yeah. So
if you just, like, yeah, try saving. Let's
see what happens in Tilt.
Okay.
So let's go back to our Tilt UI.
Alright. It it's something
Okay. So it says that it's kept my
image build because it has nowhere to deploy
it.
Yep. Now you need some Kubernetes YAML.
Alright. Unfortunately, I can generate that pretty quickly
too. So let's have a deployment dot YAML.
I love this. I don't know who wrote
this Kubernetes plug in for Versus code, but
it just simplified my life to no end.
So
the first question I have now is that
I know how to deploy NGINX.
What I don't know how to deploy is
my
Tilt one. So do I just put that
first parameter from my Tilt fail, which is
can I deploy? Yep.
And that's it.
Okay.
Oh, I didn't add the YAML. Okay. So
that's that's first lane here.
K. Tilt fail.
Is there a Versus code plugin for Tilt?
Not that I know of. If you set
it to Python, it will be fairly close.
It will give you syntax highlighting, but we'll
complain about undefined
functions.
Well, we can just ignore that. So I
I think someone wrote an extension to parse
Tilt files as Starlark.
I
I think someone
maybe that's only when you look at the
source code on GitHub. I don't know. But
I think there is something for Versus Code.
Also, something something that we don't recommend anymore,
but it's also a possibility.
So Tilt has has a CLI mode. So
run it runs things in the terminal and
then you you don't use the the dashboard
on the browser. You can run that CLI
on the terminal inside Versus Code. So that's
something you can do.
But we are kind of phasing out the
CLI and using more the browser dashboard.
So I'm not sure I would recommend that,
but it's a possibility.
So just so I can kinda see
it, what was the how do I do
the tilt in this command line mode?
I guess it's tilt up. I think you
do tilt
up,
but
you'll need to kill the other
to run Or just or just use another
parts just to see it now. So just
tilt up dash dash parts and just put,
like, ten three five six or something.
Okay. So is is dash leg dash dash
legacy the mode we're talking about? No. No.
No. Just tilt up dash dash part and
put some random number there.
Yep.
And now press t.
I quite like it.
Okay.
So I'm assuming that my web one is
still running, means
yeah. Yeah. Now
you're doing all the work twice. So ideally,
you would choose
Yeah. We'll we'll stick with the web UI.
I don't wanna use anything that's gonna disappear
eventually.
So
so what happens here is
okay. Let me scroll back up a little
bit.
So when we added the Kubernetes yep. Alright.
So no
that's my broken YAML. I fixed my broken
YAML.
It started building an image,
which actually appears to have worked.
It did
not push it and then it deployed
my application.
So it could actually be running.
Yeah. What what you would do now is
add a port forward so that you can
then access what's inside the container from the
your browser and local host.
And would I do that using
my Kubernetes tooling or is there something tilted?
Oh, no. No. Just just tilt.
There's a
maybe go back to the docs,
and and then you can just copy and
paste there.
Where is the part forward?
Yeah. That it just yeah. There we go.
Okay.
So I can
I think that's going to be engine x?
It's the name of the
the name of the Kubernetes object.
Yeah. That makes sense. So
that's automatically just gonna rerun that again,
I assume,
and
it's now rebuilding our image.
I mean, so right away, it's already taken
away three of the major pain points I
have when I developed against Kubernetes.
And
now if you go
to NGINX on the sidebar?
Oh, and if you either opt out or
opt in to the
analytics,
now you can see the port forward at
the top.
Yeah.
Engine x.
So
that also means my Dockerfail
worked, but didn't really work. I mean,
so
let me just clarify that then. Let let's
focus on the wins. It works. So
I ran an NPM
run.
I don't know.
Export.
Export. It was export, wasn't it? Mhmm.
And I'm assuming that the public directory was
oh, no. It's the public directory.
Oh, no. Out. L s out. Okay. So
it copies it from public, puts it into
out. So I just got that wrong. So
now I can update my Docker file.
And, this is just gonna just take that
change and
work.
There
we go.
So I guess my question now is, this
is leveraging just my
vanilla Docker setup to the point that I'm
gonna still get advantage of, like, all my
build cache. Although my Dockerfile is not really
made for caching right now with that copy
doc. You know, if I optimize my Dockerfile
here, it's only gonna rebuild from certain stages.
Okay. Yes.
Yeah. Go
ahead then. So it uses build kit if
you have it installed by default, so you
can use those.
And now what you're getting is
the,
you know, automated
nature of it and the UI. So if
you have more services,
you can
see them in the sidebar and, like, flip
between them, but we haven't done the the
live update
piece
to make it faster at all.
Okay. So in order for us let's let's
assume that this application is a bit more
feature complete than, like, in a static site.
So say I optimize the Dockerfile
so that we don't have to do the
NPM install every step. I think that's gonna
make this
a lot quicker for what we're doing because
the export takes less than a second.
And then I wanna add a database. Can
we kinda go through the process to see
multiple services here?
Yeah. You
you
would make another
call to Kate's YAML with the YAML for
your
other service.
Okay. So let's assume
let's
add Postgres.
Alright. Yeah. So I could so these would
be
would these be the same production YAML images
that I used,
or would there be anything there specific I
have to do or tweak
for this?
You
might not want as many, like, instances
as
your production.
What we've seen teams do is, like, if
you're already using Helm or Customize,
you, like, have, you know, a different set
of values. So it's, like, the same base
template,
but you might have, you know, just slightly
different values
so that you don't have, you know,
your development instance taking as many resources as
your production instance.
But otherwise, the same. Yeah.
Okay. So
I need to
I need to add my new resource. So
I don't like this resource. I know I
would never do Postgres this way. So I'm
gonna do it because I'm curious, and then
maybe we could talk about how I would
choose and customize to tweak my NGINX deployment,
but hang on for my Postgres one. Because
I feel like if I were trying to
build a production, like, development environment, Rawkode, that's
the tools I would
be that's the tools I think I would
choose. Yeah. Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, Postgres is now spinning up. So does
the orange mean it's pending?
It's working. Yeah.
Oh, no. No?
Yeah.
Orange means there's an alert, and you can
see that it's in a
a, yep, back off
loop. Yeah. I did provide the passwords, but
she cannot spin it up with the telling
them the passwords.
Environment,
postcard password,
password,
make it secure, one, three. Yeah.
It's green. Nice. Okay.
Although, does this orange bit mean I broke
NGINX?
That's that's gray bit. Sorry. Let's
oh, it's because
your Docker context for NGINX is docked.
It, like, includes
the postgres dot yaml.
And so you can there are, like, optional
parameters
to the Docker build so you can, like,
ignore
YAML files and things. So Tilt was,
you know, being helpful about something. You know,
you didn't actually care that this YAML was
in there,
but but it was.
Well, that respect my Docker ignore,
I guess. Okay. So I could do a
Docker ignore, and I'd say
I mean,
I can just just start on YAML for
now
and not that fast.
But I'm assuming that in itself will trigger
one rebuild, and then I'll be back to
normal. Okay. Yes.
I I agree. Let's see if the computer
agrees with I mean, we're up poking it.
But
Alright. This is this is cool. So I
tweak my Dockerfile. I'm using the build cache
to avoid a painful MPM install, and this
is much faster now. Like, that was a
few seconds, and I had my deployment. Now
the question is, did I actually fix it
or not? So
no.
No? Oops. So I take my challenge now.
I will try one more time and then
we'll just ignore it. But
if I do run our MIT
engine x and just go and save this,
I think maybe I got the directory wrong.
So if I look at the engine x
dot conf,
take a look at default.
Yeah. There we go.
So I just mounted it to the wrong
path.
Easy mistake to make.
This goes
here.
And then I will watch this nice little
UI.
It should go green pretty quickly.
These moments when we're waiting, always like to
think of silly computer jokes to tell.
Like, you know, I I would tell you
a UDP joke, but then I might have
to tell you again. So
Hey.
There you go.
Alright.
So my website, my million dollar application here,
can I deploy today? Yes. It is working.
Okay. Do you wanna do you wanna make
changes to it? Maybe tweak that text and
see how long it takes?
Yeah. Good idea.
So I can open up
I mean, don't still have a source code.
This is gonna make me millions, but it's
can I deploy today? Yes. Definitely.
And then we come back. Shit.
So now we're building an image and that's
why it takes a minute.
Now I have no idea how we're gonna
use,
live reload
on this setup, but I'm very curious to
find out.
Well, we could give it a
go. And if it doesn't work, I have
ahead of time pulled up some of these
example applications. So we can always pull down
one of these. But we can we can
go through the the motions of how we
would do this. And then if it doesn't
work, we'll we'll reevaluate. And I'm also keen
if we don't forget just to stop using
YAML
for Postgres. I'd really like to see that
help integration as well.
So if you go to the doc site,
and you go down yeah. The under enhancements,
the first one is faster development with live
update.
Okay.
So
And so the key here is
it's
doing docker build,
but, like, with live update, you're telling Tilt,
like, hey. Yeah. You can always still do
a docker build,
but there's also this, like, faster path where
I want to sync files
from
this directory
in you know, on my laptop to this
directory in the running container.
So then what do you think we should
suggest here?
Should we rebuild the NPM export stuff locally
and then sync those files to a running
container?
Or how would you do this?
So I think,
you
know, part
of like like, we want Tilt to work
with real cases.
And so, like, in real and developers
come up with shortcuts even though they don't,
like, always work. And so what I do
is probably have a live update that just
syncs,
you know, the PHP file
to the
the right place and kind of skips the
export,
which could get out of sync. And if
it does, you can, like, click rebuild in
the UI,
which will have it fall back
to the image build. So I think that
will, like, work in the, like, 90%
case.
Okay. So let me make this easier for
you both.
We don't need to use the
the export.
Let okay. I think I know
okay. I think I know what we have
to do, but what I'd really love to
understand is just a little bit about this
live update syntax. So what this does, if
I've understood correctly,
is runs
a container
and is managing the file synchronization into the
container and then running an arbitrary command when
those files change.
So what is the container
that is running? Because I have a multilayer
Dockerfile. Is that why this is a little
bit more complicated?
Yes.
It's
Tilt
isn't maintaining a separate container. It's just the
container,
like, that you're already
running.
Ah, okay. Right. I got it. I got
it. I got it. So the where you
have the text highlighted there, the line above
it docker build, it's doing the same as
you saw before. It just builds a container.
What happens is when the files specified
in the first arguments to the sync function
change,
it's going to update those files inside the
container.
And,
of course, sometimes you need to run a
special command like if your requirements change then
you need to
pip install your requirements in that example.
I hardly ever use the run function,
just the sync function. So basically, just tell
me
if these files change locally,
update those files inside the container. And basically,
that's it.
Okay. So
I think I know what we need to
do.
I'm sure I'm wrong, but I'll try anyway.
So we want to add a new parameter.
So it was just this,
and I'll put this down here so it
can imagine for example.
And I want to think
So this run trigger runs inside the container.
This sync
so with that sync, I mean, it expects
me to run,
like, an okay. Sorry. I'm not making any
sense right now. Let's take this out for
two seconds,
I'll show you what I mean. Is there
comments in the top file? Yes.
Mhmm.
But they're Python. Yeah.
Okay. So we don't need to use the
export.
If I come into my Dockerfile, and let's
just forget engine x, then we can run
the NPM
dev server.
Then what we can do is NPM
dev,
which should give us a more interactive style
environment. Let me just check. Yeah. So we
can just do this. I think and then
do you want that as an entry point?
Because I think run will run it, like,
while you're building the image.
Good catch. I
definitely do not want to run it in
the image, so that was a mistake.
Yeah. So we want entry point. We want
dev.
And
if I look at our UI,
let's see what happens here.
Because this is not a long
running process and then you run that container.
Give it a second.
Well, we broke.
Run that.
What's
developing without a few errors?
Always my errors, of course. Never the total.
It's just me.
You know, that was saying pepcak, you know,
problem exists between keyboard and chair. That's definitely
true for me. Yep.
That's why I use a standing desk, no
chair.
Alright. We have a dev server. So the
first hiccup is this port change, which I
can fix.
So that port is coming from
our
app here.
Oh, no. So that's a local port. So
that's not contained Yeah. I think it's coming
from the Dockerfile
or oh, no. This one. You're right. You're
right.
Which should reload,
and then
this shouldn't have changed here. So when that
goes green, I hopefully, I can just reload
this page.
I think I think there may just try
it again.
I think it it you may just have
caught it in the middle of the port
forward.
Yeah. Didn't didn't oh, there you go. Perfect.
Okay. So now I think we're in a
position where the live update sets the model
that you kind of expect. So
let's take pause because if this works right
now, it's gonna feel just like magic.
Let's go and do some magic now.
Alright. So I open the Tilt file. I'm
gonna bring this code back in.
And I
think you don't want any run. You just
want a sync.
Yeah.
Yeah. I'll I'll comment that out for now.
I I just wanna test the run trigger
thing. I'm a I'm a bit curious about
it. And
then this sync is what the files I
expect to
change as part of the build statement. Would
that would that just be dot, like, when
anything changes?
I think you
yes. That should work. Or would it be
public, which is where I
guess? Yeah. The the thing is you need
to choose what's gonna go where. So you
need to know what locally is gonna sync
to where inside the container.
So if you sync dot, it's gonna basically
put everything in your everything that's open on
the sidebar there into the container.
I think you don't want that.
Alright. So if I want to sync the
pages directory, which is the one I'm gonna
be modifying,
and then I put that into
oops. So where did I meant that? Slash
codes. Yep. So slash codes slash
pages.
Mhmm. Mhmm.
And let's pull up our UI, which is
now my source of healthiness, I guess.
And if this works, I should be able
to change my
my code HTML and set the pages directory,
and it will not do any more rebuilds.
It would just
match Yep. Let's try. Exactly.
Alright. So that reloaded.
Let's modify.
Let's fail again, and let's just revert it.
And I got hot reload from from
JavaScript.
Yeah.
That was awesome. That was really cool. And
if you go to the Tilt UI, you
can see what it did there.
One zero point one second to get that
change onto the container.
That's what that means. Right? I thought just
made that up. Yep.
0.13,
I guess. There's some rounding.
I'll take it. That's okay. Alright. Yeah.
Alright. That's impressive. Color me impressed. So
sorry. Need to go ahead. And the the
fun thing is that I think most front
end developers are used to having this live
refresh
depending on the framework they use but not
inside Kubernetes. Now you're doing this inside Kubernetes.
Sometimes we use a front end application to
show what's going on because it's easier to
see. Then people think, I've seen this before
in such and such framework.
But that's because we're just showing it using
a front end because it's more visual.
But this works for Go code. This works
for whatever back end language you're using. So
anything you're putting inside a container in Kubernetes,
you can use Live for Load for.
Very cool. Okay.
Alright. So
this run step piqued my interest. So I'm
curious, If I modify my package dot JSON,
which is kind of, hopefully, parallel to what
is happening with the Python example,
is that and I say trigger this failed
changes,
then
run
so that would be slash code
and
NPM install?
Yes.
And you could even say, you know what?
I don't want to do that in the
running container.
In that case, I want to, like, just
go back to, like, doing the fresh Docker
build.
So run should do what you described in
the container,
or there's also this fallback on
function
that lets you, like
yep. Change it. So it's, the power is
in your hands.
Okay. I'm
sorry. What was the
You should do what you said.
Oh, so automatically so if that command fails,
it will fall back and rebuild.
Is that Yeah. And and so I think
for this to work, you need to also
have a sync step for package dot JSON
because otherwise,
it will go, oh, like, package dot JSON.
That's a file that I don't know how
to sync.
So, like, you know, the idea that we
have with a
live update is that, like, when it doesn't
know like like, you're describing a fast path,
and sometimes you fall off that fast path,
like, if it doesn't know how to sync
package dot JSON.
So let's try this.
Yeah. This should work.
Alright. So let's modify
package
dot JSON, and let's add
I guess we could bump up a version
here. Right? So let's hope test package is
changed.
Yeah. Okay. We've got a few versions there.
So I just saved this.
Yeah. There we go.
Cool.
That that is that's a very nice feature.
I like that.
Let's tackle
Postgres.
How do I
how do I okay.
Let's how do I get rid of this
Postgres book, Yamal? And how do I consume
the Helm chart?
Or
So delete that
line,
and we should actually check perhaps,
Tilt didn't delete the
resource,
in your cluster, which maybe it should,
that's a different discussion.
Okay.
So I think I understand the challenge there.
So postcards are still running in my cluster.
Now does so what I the first question
that popped into my head there is if
I remove that from the file, Tilt reloads
that file, that resource no longer exists in
its vocabulary.
Do you store anything within the Kubernetes side
on annotations or labels to identify something as
a tilt orchestrated resource?
Yeah.
Yes.
There's metadata.
There's a managed by tilt
annotation,
and
it turns out that, like, there's a lot
of different expectations
you could have
for these. And so I think if you
run tilt down,
it will
delete
everything.
Yeah. And so it turns out life cycle
is hard. And in most of these cases,
because it's a development
instance, you know, it's it's kind
of just acceptable to say instead of figuring
out a model that the tool understands and
you understand, just, you know, delete everything
and start over
because, you know, this is kind of a
way to make your development instance cattle
in as opposed to pets.
Alright. Let me throw one and a half
questions at you there as a follow-up.
So
does Tilt Care of my Kubernetes cluster is
local or remote?
Nope.
So as the if I have a that
was a very quick answer. I like it.
If Kubernetes cluster is remote,
what if two developers are using Tilt at
the same time against the same cluster? Are
there challenges there? Or does that just work?
So I'll I'll maybe put an asterisk.
Tilt works with either local or remote,
but it has kinda like like, in it
will special case local clusters
to, like,
you know, push things in more optimal ways.
Like, it can skip the push,
and it will
require you to, like,
say which Kubernetes
context
are allowed
if it's not a local cluster so that
you can't, like, just start up Tilt against
a production cluster.
And
so if this were a remote cluster, you'd
have to kind of say, like, yes. I
want to use this context with Tilt.
And you'd probably also like, there's an extension
to add namespaces
to objects.
And so, like, in the Tilt file,
you could, like, take all the objects that
you're passing to Kubernetes YAML
And, like,
you can use you can, like, add your
username
to that namespace
by,
yeah,
using a function called local in the tilt
file to run a command. So you'd, like,
have a call local who am I, which
would return, I don't know, d mckay or
Rawkode or, like, awesome dude or whatever your
username is. And then that would actually be
a value in the Tilt file that you
pass in as the namespace.
Okay.
Got it. That makes sense.
I hear a cat.
Oh, yep.
Oh, yeah. There is a rule. If you
have animals, they always have to join us.
I'm actually Can you full screen the cat?
Yes. I can. Hold on.
He's our he's our Trigger,
which is to say he has three legs.
He's a rescue that we got a year
ago, and he is a very
curious and bitey guy.
I'm actually surrounded by animals. So I've got
five chinchillas over here, and I've got my
my ferret over here who's free roaming, who
sometimes joins the stream just to say hello.
And I have some some diggers in the
other room. And they're just over there chinchilling.
They are just chinchilling. Yeah. But I had
to turn my desk around. So my desk
in this office is a really weird angle
because people just kept asking me about my
animals during stand up all the time. Like,
oh, what's that? Sure.
Not that I don't like talking about my
animals, of course. But Yeah.
Alright.
Let's do the Helmy thingy. The Helmy thingy.
If I just search for Helm,
then Yeah. Let's let's see if our documentation's
up to date.
Yeah. I've been impressed with it so far.
So
I am just gonna copy
the I'm gonna copy the bit more complete
one. I'm feeling adventurous now. I'm getting the
hang of this. So
I'll be back in a second.
Yeah. No worries.
Oh, no. That's interesting.
Okay. So this is actually creating the YAML
and then I'm parsing it into a function.
Okay.
I need to discuss by my chart.
Now would that use Helm repositories that I
have configured locally, or it's just something I
need to do special there?
It
oh, you know, one of the advantages of
having a team is that
other people I'm not entirely sure. So let's
see.
We also can deploy a remote helm chart,
which we talk about. And
let's, yeah, let's let's
let's venture forth and see which
rocks we crash ourselves into with
gusto.
Sorry. I am no stranger to reading documentation.
In fact, the original name of the stream
was RTFM with Rawkode, but people voted against
it on Twitter. So I I got rid
of it.
So
let's see.
We can load a remote chart. We give
it a name,
and then we can execute it
like so. So let's see if I can
work this one out. If I go to
the Helmholt and
search for Postgres,
Let's use
is that the only four?
That's not right.
Let's try MongoDB.
Give me a chart I've used before, please.
Alright. Let's just pick something around on that.
It doesn't have to be a database.
Let's go with Bitnami
console.
So
that's
a okay. So extension helm remote. I don't
think I changed that because I'm obviously loading
some sort of extension,
given that name, and then I have this
chart name. So for me, would that be
no. I don't know. So
I do not have a local chart.
I think I'm gonna rate
it
with this extension.
So I think if you go for more
options, see the Helm remote read me just
a bit below your mouse,
there's a link there.
There
we go.
There. That's kinda that makes more sense.
Yeah. This example was not great for me,
but this one definitely helps.
Alright.
Oh,
Oh, chart name
will be we said console.
The repository URL I copied from Helm Hub.
I'm gonna give that a name of Bitnami.
And I wonder
my
console
And
so the values here is a list. Is
that multiple value fails
or is it key value
pairs?
Value fails. Right. Okay.
So
Let's see.
We'll have console values
dot yaml.
I'm gonna try not to see if this
failed because I'm assuming it'll be gonna break
everything.
I I think it will just, you know,
give a parse error in the
Oh, really? Okay. Let's see that. Blah blah
blah blah blah.
What happens if I do that?
Alright. Okay.
Cool. I was just curious. Yeah. No. We
we want to make it, you know, safe
for you to do things.
Well, I'm very glad that it doesn't just
kill the Tilt process, and I have the
opportunity to just go back and fix it.
So do it tail upping again. So that's
good.
We we have a we have a config
file that is safe for feline typists.
So, you know, if your cat walks over
your computer Yes.
Yes. That's a developer experience I hadn't really
thought of before, but yeah. My my favorite
loves to type in stuff random stuff.
So
I guess I don't really need to override
this value, the default one might be enough.
Plus, I don't know where it is. So
let's see. Get out
let me check.
Yeah. Okay. We'll make one change.
Console.
Values.
Okay.
Let's change
to data center name.
Okay. Rawkode.
So that should pull in my values. I
gave my release a name. I can take
out my random error.
So
my question here is,
how does Tilt discover these extensions? Is there
anything I need to do? Or does this
know what it was from a registry or
GitHub or or what?
Yep. Registry on Git sorry. L u Yeah.
We have a we have a tilt extensions
repo.
And then when you prepend
the load instruction with EXT
and all of that, then it just finds
the extension in the extension repo.
Okay.
Cool.
So I've saved that
and tried
that. I bet you I just don't have
helm installed,
which, of course, would be a bit of
a challenge. So
I'm starting to get very much used to
this Mac. I got this when I started
my new role, and I've been a Linux
user since I was, like, 16. So I
I'm hoping
this works.
Are you are you able to make the
change?
To make the jump?
It's been painful.
I keep kinda wanting to go back to
my Linux machine, but mostly for my window
manager and all my shortcuts, which have now
been disappeared. The good thing is that my
terminal hasn't really changed. I'm using all my
my Z Shell plugins. So it's going okay,
but I definitely I I've there's been some
friction and tension.
Yep.
Is that the right helm?
I bet you it's not.
Have I still told someone around? No. It
is. Okay. So we have helm. Oh, no.
But I haven't told I haven't changed the
fail. Tilt doesn't monitor my path for for
Helm. So
Yeah. You're correct.
Alright. Cool. There we go. So it's adding
the repository.
What have I got over here?
Sorry.
Like
I said, cricket is the ID.
It's it's super fun when when Dan does
that, like, in meetings and stuff.
Because you you never know you never know
if you said something
that makes no sense or if it's just
his cat. And look to, like, within two
parts in 10,000,
loading your Tilt file took five seconds.
That
is true. Just at the bottom there, successfully
loaded tilt file. Took 3.141
Oh, yeah. Four seconds.
I mean, good news is that I do
have a green my console now.
I have a restart here, but I did
just deploy a random chart without really tweaking
the parameters. So I'm gonna let that one
slide.
Alright.
So that could have been
a production post code or it could have
been a development production
could have been a post code to point
their helm with development environments configured through this
path here,
but it wasn't. But it did do what
it was supposed to do. So that's good.
Awesome.
Now one final thing,
and then we'll
we'll leave it as that. The customized thing
so the the one question I still got
kinda burning in my head right now.
The YAML files I usually have in my
repository are customized based so that I can
do multiple environments.
What is the workflow
for that?
I'm assuming
there's docs.
Yes.
Am I still yeah. That's still the helm
one.
I think for cost
yeah. I think for customize, you go to
the API and then you check the
customize function there.
So way at the bottom
no. Not not that much bottom bottom of
the menu.
Tilt to API reference.
There should be a customized function in there
somewhere.
Okay. So this is
this is all of the extensions.
If you control f, it's probably
easier. There
you go.
I think you just pointed to the customized
files. Right? Just
and I'd have to install customize first. Okay.
We don't need to go through that steps.
I've gotta trust that it just works. Plus,
I don't have any customized files locally.
So
let's take a look at that extension list
though. That was quite large.
These are the built in functions. The extensions
are are above that.
So I see decode JSON
and decode
YAML. What are the applications
or use cases for those kind of functions?
I'm not really picturing that right away.
So, like
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You might want to,
like,
have different options for, like, which servers am
I running. Right? Like
and so
an example of that is maybe you want
to, like, have preferences
that are saved.
And so the tilt file can, like, read
those
from disk and then decode them, as JSON
into, like, Python
objects
that you can, like, dig into.
Or,
some p some teams some companies
that are bigger will actually have, like, each
team
you know, they maybe already have tooling
per service. And so they have shell scripts
that create JSON per service that, like, have
info.
And so
this is really a way
like, when we say mister Rogers,
Tilt likes your project just the way it
is, One of the ways that you, like,
need to interact with it is,
getting info from existing,
you know, scripts that,
generate JSON.
And so, like, it's not kind of useful
at this point of trying Tilt where you're
getting one thing set up. It's more how
do you get it to interact with, like,
bigger existing setups.
Okay. I think I understand that.
So there are two other things that kind
of pop out here. The Docker Compose function,
I'm assuming, similar to the helm, will allow
me to load the Docker Compose
and spend that those containers up in the
background as well. I
think
Dan would like to
go on a bit of a dive digression
here and just tell you that you don't
have to use Kubernetes to use Tilt. You
can also use Tilt with Docker Docker Compose.
Or
or or
just with running, like, processes.
Like, you might say, hey. My team, yeah,
we deployed to Kubernetes,
but most of the time, we're just running,
you know, like, go install
and then ghost, you know, like, and run
that server, or we're just running NPM dev
locally.
You still have this issue of, like, searching
between different log streams.
And so the Docker Compose stuff and the
local
resource,
like,
hey. Even if you don't use Kubernetes for
dev, you solve problems that Tilt solves.
Yeah. Thank you, l. It's it's like you've
met me and know what my hobby horses
are.
I I didn't I didn't know you were
into horses.
Oh,
that's actually a whole different story. But yeah.
Alright. Okay. That's just
it caught me off guard. I didn't realize
it till didn't actually have that dependency on
Kubernetes. So that's really cool as well. Alright.
I'm gonna throw one more question at you
and then we will we we will finish
up, and I'll let you get back to
your day. This includes syntax.
Is there a use case for multiple Tilt
files, or am I misunderstanding
what that would be used for?
Yeah.
When you get to, you know, a team
that
has, you know, maybe 15 different services,
you know, and you want to turn them
on or off or, you know, we have
orgs that have hundreds of engineers that are
using Tilt,
you know, then you
don't want to just have one file that
lists everything.
And so you want to break that up.
And so
that's you know, in in this example
that you're you're seeing, it's kind of contrived.
But, you know, how do you make a
tool that's use you know, where you can
play around with it like we have been
this hour,
but also that can scale to
hundreds of
engineers.
Right? And and dozens or hundreds of services.
Right? Like,
are different constraints and trade offs to make
there.
Okay. Yeah. So, I mean, that's a I
guess, what I've got in my head for
a use case there is, you know, each
individual team is gonna be working on their
independent service with their own Tilt fail. But
if you ever wanted to orchestrate or see
them all working together in a certain fashion,
then we could choose that include syntax
to push them all to
the cluster. Okay.
Got it.
Alright. Let me remove our screen share.
So that's been
exceptionally useful. I got a much better understanding
for how Tilt works. I'm very impressed.
We didn't actually have too many snags other
than my own inability to do stuff and
type.
But it just seemed to work really well.
It definitely was
a good developer experience for working against a
Kubernetes cluster. And now I know I don't
even need the Kubernetes cluster. So I'm gonna
have to start playing with this a whole
lot more.
Are there any final thoughts from either of
you before we wrap up for today?
I was also surprised we didn't run into
snags.
Honestly,
that was a pleasant surprise for me this
this morning. I'm in The US for European
viewers.
This has been great. Thanks for having us.
Yeah.
I
think, like, making sure that devs have a
good time while they're working is basically what
got me into this whole niche,
basically. So, like, for me I'm really happy
when when I see someone set something up
and they're like, oh, this is super easy
to to set up and now it's super
easy to use and now instead of worrying
about a hundred different things, can just I
can just do my focus on my code
and work on my project and I don't
have all those other headaches.
Then, at that point, they kind of forget
that they're using this tool for it.
I think it's like
in the movie industry they say that when
you do good CG, no one notices it's
there. I think Tilt has kind of that
objective.
When we do a really good job, the
developer can just focus on their on their
project, on what they really wanna achieve, and
we just get out of the way. I
think that is the that is the main
goal.
A very good goal to have. Definitely.
Alright. Well, I just wanna say thank you
to you both for joining me and and
guiding me through this today. It's been an
absolute pleasure, and I really appreciate your time.
So thank you very much. To people watching,
I hope you've enjoyed learning about Tilt, and
you can give it a try. And if
you do, right into snags, I'm sure Dan
and Ellen would be happy to answer questions
on Twitter. But I'm sure you would because
it just works.
Alright.
Thanks so much. Thank you. I'll speak to
you all soon. Have a nice day. Cheers.